♪ ♪
>> Laura: IT’S MEDICINES PINUP
BOY DR. ANTHONY FAUCI THOUGHT
TODAY’S HEARING WOULD BE ANOTHER
FONDA FEST, HE WAS IN FOR A RUDE
AWAKENING.
AT ST. ANTHONY HAD TO CONTEND
WITH REAL YET FAIRLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD QUESTIONS FROM
HONEST MEN JIM JORDAN.
>> WHEN DO AMERICANS GET THEIR
FREEDOM BACK?
>> WHEN WE GET THE LEVEL OF
INFECTION IN THIS COUNTRY LOW
ENOUGH THAT IT IS NOT --
>> WHAT IS LOW ENOUGH?
GET ME NUMBER.
>> TO GET THE LEVEL OF INFECTION
LOW AND IT’S NO LONGER A THREAT,
THAT IS WHEN PERIODS BECAUSE YOU
DON’T THINK AMERICANS LIBERTIES
HAVE BEEN THREATENED?
>> I DON’T LOOK AT THIS IS A
LIBERTY THING.
>> TELL ME THE NUMBER.
>> WHEN 90% OF MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS GET VACCINATED.
>> TIME HAS EXPIRED, YOU NEED TO
RESPECT THE CHAIR AND SHUT YOUR
MOUTH.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN FROM OHIO
OHIO, CONGRESSMAN, LET’S START
WITH YOU.
FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD QUESTION,
ONE WE HAVE BEEN ASKING SINCE
LAST APRIL, GIVE US OBJECTIVE
METRICS, WHEN CAN KIDS GO BACK
TO SCHOOL, WE KNOW IT’S NOT
DANGEROUS, WHEN CAN WE GET OUR
FREEDOM BACK AND ALWAYS MOVING
THE GOAL POSTS.
AND HIS GUARDIANS RUSHED IN TO
DEFEND HIM.
>> IN WHAT WORLD DOES AN
UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS GET TO
TELL AMERICAN CITIZENS WHEN WE
CAN EXERCISE OUR GOD-GIVEN
LIBERTIES, WHEN WE CAN EXERCISE
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS IN
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS?
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN TOLD YOU
CAN’T GO TO CHURCH, CAN’T GO TO
WORK, CAN’T GO TO SCHOOL, CAN’T
GO TO LOVED ONES FUNERAL, CAN’T
ASSEMBLE -- FOR A YEAR NOW,
CITIZENS HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO
COME TO THEIR CAPITAL TO LOBBY
THEIR REPRESENTATIVES TO
PETITION THEM TO REDRESS THEIR
GRIEVANCES.
IF YOU DARE SPEAK OUT AGAINST
DR. FAUCI, YOU GET CENSORED CAN
BE ATTACKED.
DR. BLACK HE’S A PHYSICIAN AND A
MEDICAL PROFESSOR FROM STANFORD,
EVEN THAT’S NOT A GOOD ENOUGH
FOR THE RADICAL LEFT.
THAT IS WHAT IS DRIVING ME CRAZY
AND WE LIKE TO KNOW, YOU ARE ONE
OF THE VERY FIRST TO POINT THIS
OUT A YEAR AGO ON YOUR SHOW.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF
THIS AND JUST TELL US WHEN IT’S
GOING TO END, WHEN WE GET OUR
RIGHTS BACK.
>> Laura: I GUESS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE TO REMEMBER THE
GOVERNMENT CAN’T TAKE CERTAIN
RIGHTS AWAY, THOSE ARE
INALIENABLE RIGHTS.
LIFE, LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
HE DOESN’T HAVE THE RIGHT AND
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN’T HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TAKE A LOT OF THESE
BASIC FREEDOMS AWAY.
I WANT TO GO TO YOU ON THIS
BECAUSE WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF CASES IN THE
COMMUNITIES BUT YOU SEE HOW HE
GOT VERY NERVOUS WHEN HE WAS
ASKED FOR A SPECIFIC NUMBER.
WHY IS THAT?
>> THERE IS NO NUMBER OTHER THAN
ZERO THAT WILL SATISFY HIM.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
CASES ARE NOT THE PROBLEM, CASES
IN THE VULNERABLE POPULATION IS
THE PROBLEM AND ONCE WE HAVE
VACCINATED THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION, WE ARE DONE WITH THE
EPIDEMIC.
YOU ASKED ABOUT SCHOOLS, WE
SHOULD OPEN SCHOOLS TOMORROW,
THERE’S NO EXCUSE NOT TO HAVE
THEM OPEN IMMEDIATELY.
I THINK WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS, 80% OF PEOPLE 65 AND
UP IN THE U.S. HAVEN’T HAD THEIR
FIRST DOSE OF THE VACCINE --
DR. FAUCI IS PROBABLY THE NUMBER
ONE ANTI-VAX IN THE U.S. IN SOME
SENSE, HE HAS MODELED BEHAVIOR
MAKING PEOPLE THINK THE VACCINE
WON’T GIVE YOU BACK YOUR LIFE,
IT WILL, IT’S AN INCREDIBLY
EFFECTIVE VACCINE.
HE HAS BEEN VACCINATED, I DON’T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT HE’S
TRYING TO DO AND I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH REPRESENTATIVE JORDAN
JORDAN.
DR. FAUCI IS UTTERLY BLIND TO
THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE IN A
LOCKDOWN INCLUDING OUR LIBERTY
BUT ALSO OUR HEALTH.
>> Laura: LATER IN THE HEARING
I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS MISSED
IT, YOU CONTINUED TO PRESS
DR. FAUCI ON WHEN WE COULD FULLY
OPEN THE COUNTRY.
>> GIVE US YOUR BEST GUESS THAT
IN.
>> I JUST DID TO.
>> YOU DIDN’T GIVE US A TIME,
ARE WE GOING TO BE HERE TWO
YEARS FROM NOW?
>> YOUR RANTING AGAIN.
>> I’M NOT RANTING NOT RANTING.
>> YES YOU ARE.
>> Laura: THAT WAS A PERSONAL
ATTACK.
WE HAVE THE ROSE PARADE IN 2025,
THE SUPER BOWL FULLY ATTENDED IN
2026, HE DOESN’T WANT TO BE
SPECIFIC, EVER.
>> THE TAXPAYERS OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY WHOSE LIBERTIES HAVE
BEEN INFRINGED AND ASSAULTED AND
ATTACKED FOR THE LAST YEAR PAY
THIS INDIVIDUAL $470,000 A YEAR,
THE HIGHEST-PAID BUREAUCRAT IN
IN THE ENTIRE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WHY CAN’T HE GIVE US AN ANSWER?
LET’S GET BACK TO ALLOWING THIS
COUNTRY TO FLOURISH LIKE IT WAS
BEFORE THIS VIRUS HITS THE
EARTH.
IT IS SO OBVIOUS WE NEED TO GET
BACK TO RESPECT IN THE
CONSTITUTION, EVERY SINGLE RIGHT
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT HAS
BEEN ATTACKED OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF OTHER
COSTS THE DOCTOR POINTED OUT TO.
A SOCIAL COST, HEALTH COSTS,
CERTAINLY ECONOMIC COSTS, I KNOW
THIS VIRUS IS SERIOUS BUT LET’S
GET BACK TO NORMAL.
>> Laura: GIVEN YOUR
PROFESSIONAL OPINION WITH ALL OF
THE FACTS THAT WE KNOW AND WE’VE
KNOWN FOR ALMOST A YEAR ABOUT
THIS VIRUS, IT CAN BE DEADLY IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES ESPECIALLY
WITH PEOPLE WITH HIGH BMI --
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW, ARE THESE
CONTROLS ON PERSONAL FREEDOMS,
DO THEY SEEM TO BE TAILORED TO A
CONCERN ABOUT A VIRUS OR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
>> I DON’T WANT TO SECOND-GUESS
BUT I WILL SAY THEY HAVEN’T BEEN
EFFECTIVE AT STOPPING THE VIRUS.
FLORIDA IS RELATIVELY OPEN AND
CALIFORNIA’S LOCKDOWN.
THE DEATH IS WORSE IN
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE PAID AN
ENORMOUS COSTS IN TERMS OF THE
LOCKDOWNS IN SO MANY WAYS AND
YET WE’VE GOTTEN VERY LITTLE FOR
IT.
WE HAVE TO LEARN TO LIVE WITH
THIS VIRUS, IT’S NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY AND IN MANY WAYS WE HAVE
WITH THE VACCINE.
DR. FELT SHE SHOULD BE TOUTING
THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT THIS AND
TELLING THE TRUTH WHICH IS THAT
WE ARE VERY, VERY CLOSE TO BEING
ABLE TO SAY WE ARE DONE WITH THE
EPIDEMIC, WE JUST NEED TO GET
THE VACCINES IN THE ARMS OF THE
VULNERABLE.
>> Laura: THEY WANT A NEW
NORMAL, THE OLD NORMAL THEY
NEVER LIKED.
THIS GIVES THEM A CHANCE TO HAVE